so I'm any fun facts about sound editing
you want to impart mr. know-it-all to
them your students I think you're just
jealous of my knowledge of the sound
industry oh that's right you made that
movie blow out right all right for
achieving and sound editing are Richard
King for Master and Commander the far
side of the world
Gary wide stream and Michael Silver's
for finding me Christopher boys and
George waters the second from Pirates of
the Caribbean the curse of the Black
Pearl and the Oscar goes to - Richard
King for Master and Commander the far
side of the world
this is the first Academy Award at
nomination for Richard king
what to thank the Academy this
incredible honor my crew
Lindy Annie Andrew Bach Michael Mitchell
Hamilton sterling helo Eng Michael
McGill Chris flick Gary Hecker Bob
Kaiser Laura Graham Monique savato John
Fazal and Eric Potter everyone at fox
especially Jeff harlacher our brilliant
picture editing department led by Lee
Smith my good friends and fellow sailors
Paul Massey and Don Campbell and most of
all I like to think our captain Peter
Weir your vision is honored here Peter
and I was thrilled to be along for the
ride thank you and finally I'd like to
dedicate this to my beautiful wife Sue
my son Sam and to the memory of my
mother who will always be in our hearts
thank you
it's now official there is nobody left
in New Zealand to thank